there anybody that you really want to
work with oh tate i feel like every
interview i've done i'm like tate
mcgrath jay mcrae
lauren over there oh i love her she has
been talking about you apparently a lot
that she wants to collaborate with you i
love her
keisha shantae is really out here making
dreams come true while on the red carpet
at iheart radio's kiss fm wango tango
event in los angeles keisha caught up
with our canadian gal lauren spencer
smith who shared that she's manifesting
a collaboration with another canadian
music queen tate mccray how do we make
that happen what's the mind i could
probably just message her
i guess we're kind of friends put on
like a fangirl
yeah or maybe just do like a compilation
of all the time yeah
yeah maybe
you're gonna be like she's obsessed with
that
i would be like yes i am so i had to say
something because
she's
incredible oh my god her voice is
amazing maybe i was holding on to what i
thought you were but when you think too
hard eventually it starts to hurt the
version of you in my head now i know it
wasn't true young people fall for the
wrong people guess my one was you and
while we're confident that lauren will
continue to talk about her love for tate
tate spilled the tea to keisha about who
she's fangirling over at the moment and
i think we can all relate
so many people
like literally everyone um yeah i mean
right now like
jack harlow
jack um the weekend the weekend jake
fangirl i mean justin bieber uh
whoa it is the sparkle in your eyes i
know right i'm like legit a fan girl